das wird sie ihre praxen jetzt bestimmt
fast einmal genauso viele menschen der
fan träumen astronaut zu werden wir
wissen nur ganz ganz wenige schaffen da
ist es ein unfassbares auswahlverfahren
dass man das schaffen muss auch
körperlich viele tests und jetzt können
also irgendwann so ist der plan
irgendwelche leute da hoch legen wir
haben gerade über gesprochen das alter
ist anscheinend jetzt schon kein
ausschlusskriterium mehr ist denn das
wirklich sicher oder sind diese kräfte
selbst dann so hoch dass man eigentlich
vorher genaue kontrollen haben müsste
wenn man überhaupt in diese zivile raum
fall wenn ich mal so nennen möchte
setzen darf nicht mit ja also wie gesagt
das sind jetzt erstmal extrem erhöhen
für gesungen wir nicht mal nennen
natürlich muss sich qualifiziert seien
wie gesagt es ist erwähnt worden schon
gelernt es mit 77 toten stadt geschoben
für zehn zwölf tage das geht alles wenn
man gesund ist wenn man fit ist
in eine stabile erdumlaufbahn
das ist doch mal mehr da habe ich mehr
sprechen
darf ich sie eine ganz große verbrechen
mit herrn böhme darüber sprechen wir
sehen gerade die live bilder und die
maschine startet jetzt was sehen wir was
passiert gerade im prinzip sehen wir
jetzt eigentlich ein normales im
flugzeug abheben das ist auch für doch
sicher auch jetzt für die passagiere
genauso anfühlen wie bei einem normalen
flugzeug staat auch mit denselben
beschleunigung also besitzen sie da
gerade wie sehen die sitzen dahinter
das sieht man jetzt nicht mal sicher
diese zwei außenpositionen die sind auch
innen genau so aufgebaut wie das kleine
raumschiff in der mitte zu
trainingszwecken aber das eigentliche
raumschiff ist quasi zwischen den beiden
flugzeugteilen hören das jubeln jetzt
auch also die räder die langsam von der
startbahn runter gehen jetzt ist es
abgefunden und tatsächlich sieht aus wie
ein etwas futuristisches flugzeug im
ersten moment für uns alle
das geht jetzt auch ungefähr 15
kilometer hoch wie hoch ist denn so ein
linienflieger wenn ich nach amerika auf
die ganze schon eine lange strecke zum
vergleich unter ihnen nämlich eine also
das ist jetzt nicht groß anders wollen
das ist ja das auch genau der punkt also
bis dahin ist noch alles sehr normal
das wird in dem augenblick besonders wo
die auf den knopf drücken und das kleine
dinge in der mitte heraus fällt nach
unten
wie lange dauert das ungefähr bis sie
die höhe erreicht haben mit so einem
flieger
das ist eine gute frage wie die jetzt
fliegen also ich glaube wenige minuten
bis zehn minuten das müssen wir jetzt
mal im flugplan gucken und das ganze ist
ja insgesamt ein relativ kurzes
unterfangen so zu sagen es sind wenige
minuten bis es dann wirklich losgeht
aber dann auch keine lange fahrt mehr
oder ein langer flug der eigentlichen
rakete nennt man das überhaupt rakete
was sie da gleich es ist ein
raketentriebwerk also das kann man schon
sagen also es ist ein raketen
betriebenes raumschiff das kann man
sagen
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren